alors j'avais eu des hauts et des bas en
berne une interview à bandar
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous préférez en vous
christophe mon sale caractère ouais
qu'est-ce que vous haïssez en vous son
amour propre salle prononçant le
caractère qu'est ce que vous préférez
dans la télé je préfère la télé
généreuse à la télé mes chances
qu'est-ce que courbis
est ce que vous détestez à la télé je
déteste les émissions qui font croire
qu'elles rendent service aux gens et
qu'ils ne rendent pas sérieuse autrement
dit la télé réalité bien sûr mais pas
seulement tous ces gens qui ne se passe
déclaré télé réalité mais qui en fait
font de la télé réalité qui disent ah le
pauvre le pauvre toxicomanes qu'on va
faire témoigner et puis ça va lui rendre
service en fait ça rend jamais service à
personne la télé c'est juste du
spectacle donc j'aime bien les gens qui
assument qui font du spectacle voilà
votre émission favorite
traite entrer l'accusé et les missions
vous trouvez la plus nulle la télé ça
dépend des jours il ya des émissions qui
sont jugées globalement nul par
l'intelligentsia et que moi je regarde
avec délectation certains soirs parce
que j'ai juste envie de nous prendre la
tête exemple qu un exemple de miss
france exemple bataille et fontaine
voilà des choses
que j'ai eu des morts d'autant
qu'au fond de moi j'ai pleuré
en regardant bataille et fontaine j'ai
pleuré
régulièrement s'applique aux émotions
que je m'étais tire un poil du cuse
aulas on se le garde pour moi c'est si
vous voulez c'est compliqué de dire des
choses comme ça relève de ma vie privée
donc ma vie privée et privés l'un des
plus grands le deuxième ils connaissent
les limites de la maison qu'est ce que
tu préfères dans ta vie privée
non tout ça ce sont des choses privées
ont forcément les grandcombiens la vie
sont des choses qui relève de l'intimité
et se sont pas ceux sont pas des choses
que j'ai envie de raconter mais il fait
est-ce que c'est pas seulement est ce
que ce n'est pas de la prétention de
dire le plus grand moment de ma vie je
peux pas vous le raconter c'est quoi le
plus grand moment de votre vie c'est un
jour non compressé vote en
faire quelque chose c'est trop intime
que c'est ma prétentieux ça comme
attitude de pensée de penser que le plus
grand moment de sa vie n'est pas
racontable non mais c'est pas un peu
hautain sahin
je me suis tu n'as fait pas un peu tard
je suis je suis je serai là dessus
crétins jusqu'au bout je vais marquer
goûter sur ma vie privée vraiment
prétentieux marc boutet des jeux soisy
j'ai pas choisi une vie publique je
présente au journal télévisé
elle présentait non mais mais mais les
choses qui les meilleurs moments de ma
vie ce sont des choses qui sont vraiment
là le pire alors leur exemple le
le christophe le pire moment de votre
vie c'est aussi un thème c'est aussi
privés ou à des fans au privé partout
c'est à dire si l'attaqué raison s'ils
disent que je devrais faire c'est
inventer elle dira que le vrai contrôle
et voilà et personne pourrait contrôler
et 20 banques or quel est le moment le
plus moyen de votre vie
à ça je peux répondre à ta gagner un
point c'est bien ça je peux répondre à
tes moyens 1 ma présentation du journal
de 13h sur france 2 pas mal mais j'ai
rentré dans les détails à quel âge tu as
fais l'amour pour la première
c'est avec un mec et il faudrait que je
réponde à ça parce que je fais pas ce
que je fais une émission sur france 2
non mais christophe christophe tu sais
bien qu'en disant rien tu fait fantasmer
tout le monde c'est la première fois à
troyes et oui mais au rang c'est la vie
près c'est marrant c'est comme si on
n'avait pas le choix au fond quoi
puisqu'en dix ares en rien je fait
fantasmer donc il faut que je déballe et
bien non et les gens donc à fantasmer si
ça les amuse qu'il n'y a pas matière ce
qui me fait le plus rire dans ma vie ni
graphique série va aussi voilà
sérieusement la personne qui me fait le
plus rire c'est nul de faire cela parce
que c'est nul c'est vraiment bon c'est
comme ça la vraie réponse la personne
qui me fait le plus rire aujourd'hui
c'est lui bravo merci
je propose à merci
non je trouve ça pas très gentil pour
alain et maurice que je sais que
j'accepte le complément mais on fait un
film très sérieux ce coup-ci city est ce
qui vous fait le moins rire dans la vie
à loos qui me fait le moins arrive dans
la vie ce qui me fait gerber dit pas le
nom ce serait fonction non
la presse de trottoirs vraiment vraiment
et ça je je je gilles aymard vient ça
vous voyez j'ai gardé j'ai gardé une
certaine virginité quand même parce que
j'avais envie je suis pas allé jusqu'au
bout mais d'aller voir arnaud lagardère
qui est propriétaire d'un certain nombre
de deux titres qui sont vraiment des
torchons vont bien dire mais pourquoi
est-ce à honorer votre groupe de les
vendre bien sûr qu' il serait repris par
d'autres mais qu' aujourd'hui dans le
portefeuille du groupe lagardère il y
est il ici paris il y ait france
dimanche je trouve ça n'honore pas un
groupe social alors les gens me disent
oui me vend aussi des armes c'est autre
chose mais c'est un non sens les armes
mais
j'aurais ces deux journaux dans mon
portefeuille je m'en débarrasse ray
juste pour que ça fasse pas tache mais
j'avais patron d'un groupe de presse à
voilà votre plus belle histoire d'amour
christophe je crois qu'on peut le dire
vous connaissez déjà la réponse la plus
minable idem il ya un truc c'est obligé
de répondre là ce que vous avez de plus
sexy en vo ou là ça c'est un autre
problème mais j'aime pas parler de moi
je n'en ai aucune idée c'est à dire que
je n'ai pas
vous n'êtes pas tout vu alors les yeux
s'ils le disent et de moins sexy
je dois voir je pense que ça n'est pas
très sexy de 3,4 kilos de trop allez là
c'est
si vous les aimez cela est coquet oh la
la il est très coquette avec gym pas
parler de moi c'est une horreur et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater le in a
l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu